[Music]
in adulting class news oh yeah submitted
by hi I'm Gabriel
hi got a new school in Portland teaches
Millennials how to adult wow I need to
know this they should have that in every
high school Wow awesome like how to do
taxes and all that stuff just like real
life application taxes and Roth IRA
listen up how did you plan B how to get
over a hangover that's also pretty good
yeah because the fun out of life you
know you you gotta learn that [ __ ] on
your own you know I mean you learn a
lesson better if it's first hand yeah
getting an instruction bicycle so by by
any chance you your boyfriend comes in
you and you think you're pregnant go to
Planned Parenthood I imagine if you
heard that and you're like in the third
grade I feel like they wouldn't put that
in the curricula remember sex education
when you're in like the third grade
that's a 30 I was in high school I would
say seventh grade we have to ask you
have to have them clarify what element
chickens for me my elementary was first
before kindergarten so six yep okay so
credit okay they didn't teach us
anything about vagina or pain a penis
exactly take nice Acosta I continue this
adulting school is located in me portly
me and it's founded by two women that
actually decided to create this because
what they were saying is that public
education over the years they have like
changed in date develops into like
fitting in other classes right and so as
years passed by like home economic
classes tend to like be phased out or
even like like some because I remember
in middle school I learned like how to
like balance checkbooks and what mm-hmm
and then also like learn how to like
bake and like to do other like stuff
that you could do by yourself at home
dad you're on a break that's home
economics your basement [ __ ]
I didn't take it either but I see people
coming out of that crowd baking some
[ __ ] I wish I would have taken that now
that I know we had that in high school
not metal no like wood shop yeah yeah
classes like those have been slowly like
phased out over time and so what these
two women want to do is that they want
to help millenials relearn or like learn
some of the basics that you don't learn
in school that's also how to spell like
how to handle your money how to how to
save a lot of people my age me to take
this class I know I would love to be in
there just get everything
what about how to handle heartbreak you
can they do that one I so in the article
they do mention like social skills but
they didn't go to invest about it so
pickup lines could be a good one yeah so
they have six topics that they like to
focus in this is all school which is
money work building relationships
community health of wellness and
do-it-yourself it's so good so bad
[ __ ] two women how to not punch
somebody when you man that's what I
needed to learn that's so cool to see
non-dancers do it not deaf excuse yeah
that's the first thing that any dancer
has ever taught me you need to learn on
everyone knows what a - Meghan she's a
ballet dancer it's so true I think it's
actually do a ballet dancer mark is a
come on track Tichenor this is dancing
McKinney hey I'm a [ __ ] lying down on
my in Arline lion I use a live at
factory line dancing this funny visual I
got hit see that one that's a hit okay
well real Casso because like that stuff
is so freakin useful and I know that
everybody even like our social circles
are like doing wish we would have
learned that kind of stuff in high
school like the exact time where it's
like hey you're about to go off and be
an adult right here are the tools to be
an adult that just makes sense I kind of
change a tire or something just some
basic [ __ ] which is what they mentioned
in here how to change your tire how to
change your oil is a basic first aid in
that maybe possibly in that I don't know
any of that
yeah like that stuff with totally help
or like what to do when somebody needs
help even just the idea or like how do I
oh yeah like the standard operating
procedures of basic life things yeah oh
[ __ ] there's emergency ah jump-starting
the car right what else is there
namely breaking a window and stealing a
car in a time of an apocalypse then
lugging one I wondered I'll teach a
class is this only one school right now
yeah to my knowledge is really one
school but they also offer online
classes too okay yeah and so they have a
$20 per month subscription dang brand
the program and sell that [ __ ] to every
major district that's some worthy stuff
so it's really cool to that on their
website also offers a free adulting IQ
just to determine like how much like
this person needs to learn all these
people are all they test you first to
see where you stand
how long to take maybe if we all take it
together we'll get it really nice
morning I want to share how stupid I am
lesan what about collective like an
escape room I'm not stupid
from what I know is that when you take
this quiz some of them are yes and no
questions and I have a few right here
that's it so number one is I can hang a
picture on my wall no yes oh oh it's
like oh it's really like are you capable
of right you're talking about like weird
like I'm the landlord or like quite a
bit oh yeah what the [ __ ] like do I know
how to download a level or app on my
iPhone and make sure that it's not it's
pretty cool you know what I do contract
for a picture for one picture is it like
basically it's like knowing to nail the
the nail hammer the nail at an angle 45
degrees up right on an emotional evening
Zoar knowing when to use two nails maybe
drywall you need to put in like a
drywall little plug or whatever the
fun's done are you guys serious about
taking this quiz because literate
I am a couple of questions okay I'm
going to take all of it
well I'll send you tell me for the quiz
delinquents quit I'm just going to list
a few questions that I have here alright
so another one is I can patch a hole in
a wall no sure I can but do I want to no
not the point of this quiz next one for
sure know how to YouTube how to do so
yeah yeah that's the other thing I do
you to watch those guns buddy
oh sorry I know how to put in a spare
tire yup yeah I do that three times
you know how many high is my [ __ ]
tire pop you and afterwards the adults
yeah but you after three times I
realized triple-a is the way to go
it is yeah I have no yeah I waste so
much time I rather just panic oh I pull
over to the side trooper I help me and
then a guy comes and he [ __ ] does it
while you're inside the car whoo
while you're inside the car use a lot
the truck will do it for me so we're
gonna hardcore parties extra 100 right
in town just a the cars I'm [ __ ]
traumatized dude that shouldn't scare
when your [ __ ] tire pops and you're
in a threeway you're like [ __ ] you have
to put on the [ __ ] emergency
emergency hope everyone's easy you know
that's [ __ ] real dog I've never felt
it I mean it I never felt it it's scary
cuz it's not like someone's hitting a
college Oh sounds rubber literally just
flapping ya understand your car I've
been fortunate I don't know if I felt it
like that but not only happens when
you're driving really fast so why we
haven't we haven't felt that the girls
are the only ones that haven't felt that
the freeways tomorrow tires are sad yeah
I know how to build a positive credit
history yes
and important details of credit debit
card and loan offer yeah Joe I'll just
silent over like I'm the last one I have
is I rock basic budgeting you rock basic
budgeting I'm not answering like I rock
yeah you you they wrote that yeah wow
they're like their lingo basic yeah only
no [ __ ] epic budgeting oh where is
you don't even got a look at the price
tag because you budget so well and it's
intuitive I am intuitive budgeting I
never get surprised at the bill you know
why because everything's on automatic so
if I spend it one month too much guess
what it's never going below what I have
in the checking account oh yeah that is
basic budgeting then it's intuitive
budgeting because I don't budget
Hollywood ever you want I don't budget
at all it just happens it's like
breathing now after you take this quiz
if you fail if you receive a failing
grade I try to sound like I'm rich I'm
just letting you know let them know that
it's kind of like waking up in the
morning I am like it's kind of like
doing something you know like routine
you wake up in the morning drink water
take a Dookie if you do that for how
many years you don't think about it
anymore
it just happened this quiz will tell you
sorry to break it to you
your parents are tired of your daily
calls for help and then they'll help you
out
so there's sassy and cute with ya don't
that's why I developed that second
nature ain't got no motion pairs to back
me up
that's why it's either learn how to do
this [ __ ] or you die [ __ ] poor as it
is EU needs a hug that's a cry for a hug
no no no no no stay away that was a cry
for help
I'm very conflicted he doesn't
understand what's happening here I'm
trying to teach that's a cry for hug
there it is I mean like a job Joe good
job
Morocco's look god I've been [ __ ]
raped let's go what's connected and I
help kids who just graduated from
college like how to do their laundry
their taxes like what salons are like
I'd like it more even for retirement
super good one yeah I got my nephew a
book he just turned eighteen just
graduated high school and I got him this
big fat [ __ ] book that does
essentially everything that this course
can I do actually giving okay how to
change your oil change your tire all of
that yeah
hi act like a gentleman that's a whole
school sound like a lot of emotions
we're coming out of that expression
right now that's what happens you get
ugly guys hope you guys enjoyed that
episode if you guys have any juicy
little guts of details and you guys want
to submit it well guess what you can
cruise on over to the description box
below click on the link submit the story
and hopefully we will pick it and talk
about it for more videos click right
over here
[Music]